when I was recording the video about
Capone is iam or Kaepernick OMERS I
would like to call it I said that I
didn't have a tie with element 112 on it
I hope those of you if you're watching
if you're manufacturing ties I'm in the
market for a new one or you can send me
one to advertise and while I was on
holiday a letter arrived from Germany
from the Institute where they've made
all the elements from a hundred and
seven up to one hundred and twelve and
they sent me a tie and which has got all
of the elements I'll unpack it in front
of you it's got all the different
elements they've made you can see here
and how they decay but they haven't yet
put in 112 because the name hasn't been
decided and what happens is of course is
that when they form one of these
elements it decays from one radioactive
element to another so what these are
showing are the way they decay so when
you make one of these elements it's only
short-lived and it decays but it doesn't
just decay once it decays to a whole
series of elements so if you look here
element Boreum decays to form good Neum
and then to rudder for diem or here we
have done start him that goes to hassium
and then ciborium rather for diem
nobelium and so on so it's going to be
really fun to wear though I might have
to have a different color shirt to make
it look nice
and all being well I want to go and
visit the Institute so that we can
actually see where these elements have
been made